now this morning we have an opportunity
to explore one of the cornerstones of
physics that is quantum mechanics and
our guide is dr. Steven Gervin now dr.
Gervin is a professor of physics and
applied physics and is interested in
quantum mechanics particularly in the
development of quantum computers along
with his colleagues in engineering
doctors Deborah ray and Scholl cough
they've fabricated an artificial atom
using the same fabrication techniques
that are used for integrated circuits
the processes that are inside of your
computers and and using these methods
what they'll learn they'll be able to
connect the physics of our world to the
physics of the micro world so we're
really in for a great treat
so with that please sit back and help me
welcome dr. gurbin to the podium okay
we'll see if the classical computer
works here
okay good morning so I'm gonna tell you
a little bit about a very interesting
and very famous physicist Richard
Feynman and about quantum mechanics
which is a subject that is near and dear
to the hearts of all physicists and and
Richard Fineman invent in quantum
mechanics is a very rich theory it has
there are many different ways you can
look at it and Richard Feynman invented
a particular way of describing how tiny
particles like atoms and electrons and
particles of light called photons move
around and they move in ways which are
make no sense whatsoever I'm going to be
telling you things that sound completely
crazy and completely incorrect and it
was extremely difficult for the people
who invented quantum mechanics to
believe that these really crazy things
were happening and it was just just such
a strange turn of events to understand
that reality doesn't work the way we
think it works and of course nowadays
that quantum mechanics is 75 or 80 years
old and we've gotten used to it there
are still surprises and and the fact
that you could perhaps someday build a
computer that behaves quantum
mechanically is an idea that's only
about 15 years old and was quite a
surprise when people realized that it
was true things are so strange so you
might if you're interested in what I
talked about today it it really follows
from this little book by Richard Feynman
QED quantum electrodynamics the strange
theory of light and matter
things are so strange that in the early
days people like Niels Bohr who helped
invent the subject of quantum mechanics
if someone came with a new idea he would
say well that's crazy but it may not be
crazy enough to explain what's going on
you can also look at some
gonna have some demonstrations at the
end and there are some photos of those
and some background material that are
visible on my my webpage so before I
start I might just tell the kids here a
little bit about my own background
because it's a little unusual I grew up
in a tiny village in northern New York
State in the Adirondack Mountains there
were five kids in my high school class
we had no library the math teacher
taught business arithmetic that was as
high as it went didn't have a physics
teacher and but with good luck and some
help from some of my teachers and my
parents I was I didn't have enough money
to go to college but I was able to get a
scholarship and was able to do fulfill
my dream and become a physicist so I
encourage you to think past the the
doughnuts and what's on television this
afternoon and think ahead to what you're
going to do with your lives and think
about the possibilities of becoming a
scientist becoming a teacher
becoming a musician whatever it is that
you want to do and I hope you are able
to fulfill your dream as as I have okay
so mr. Fineman so richard fineman was a
very interesting guy there are a lot of
when you go to physics graduate school
you learn all kinds of stories about him
some of them are even true and he
certainly did nothing to discourage lots
of stories about himself and he's been
described as no ordinary genius when I
mean a sort of ordinary genius as
somebody who is so smart they do this
brilliant new thing and you say to
yourself well if only I had been ten
times smarter maybe I could have done
that but Fineman was somebody who just
seemed to come up with new ideas and
results magically and you say to
yourself I have no idea how he did that
and no matter how smart I am I could
never do that and he liked to play a lot
of practic
jokes and when he worked on the
Manhattan Project during World War two
at Los Alamos where the atomic bomb was
built he used to like to break into
safes and leave notes for the security
people saying you should really lock up
these secrets more carefully
he also while he was there
invented that they had to do a lot of
computing and in those days they didn't
have computers well the word computers
meant a person who used a mechanical
adding machine to do calculations and he
had T he was in charge of a large team
of army privates with these Martian
calculators mechanical calculators and
he invented new ways of speeding up
calculations that are very practical and
are used in your PC today so called
vector processing he also is sort of the
Godfather of nanoscience or one of the
godfathers he got interested in the idea
in the 1950s about how small you could
make things could you make a transistor
that just was made of a few atoms or
could you build a really tiny tiny
electrical motor and he offered a prize
of several thousand dollars to somebody
the first person who could make a motor
electrical motor that was smaller than a
64th of an inch on a side a figuring he
would never have to pay off and about a
year later this guy William McClelland
presented him with this little
electrical motor you can see the wires
coming out here and that's the head of a
pin so I don't know how this person
machined that little motor but it they
looked at it under a microscope and they
could see it turning around so Feynman
had to pay him $1,000 okay so onto
quantum mechanics so well first before
we understand quantum mechanics we have
to understand what mechanics is so
mechanics is the study of how things
move
it's not necessarily the study of how
you repair cars and how things move
while planets move in orbits around the
Sun if you're an auto mechanic you want
to see how well your car accelerates if
you play baseball you want to understand
the trajectory of the of the pop fly
going into left field and in the last
300 years starting with Galileo and
Newton physicists have come to
understand that there are laws that can
allow you to predict if you know the
initial velocity and direction of the
baseball you can calculate how it's
going to go up and gravity's going to
pull it down and you can calculate the
path that it's going to take and it was
understood and everything seemed fine
until the the beginning of the last
century around 1900 everything seemed
fine
physicists seemed to understand
everything but then people realized that
things were made of very tiny particles
atoms and then they discovered the
electron and then they discovered
particles of light that light was not a
wave but made of particles called
photons and they found out that all the
laws of physics that we thought were so
perfect are actually only approximations
which work for large objects like
baseballs but fail completely for tiny
objects and the thing that's going on
with my experimental colleagues are
trying to build a quantum computer here
in this building upstairs on the fourth
floor they're trying to make relatively
large objects objects that contain
around a hundred billion atoms which is
still very so tiny you have to look at
it under microscope but it's much larger
than one of them they're trying to make
those rather large objects behave
quantum mechanically and it's very very
difficult but they're making a lot of
progress so what what happens with the
laws of physics is that it turns out you
cannot say if you throw a baseball and
it's nice and massive
you can say look it was here that it was
there that it was there than it was
there it moved on this trajectory and I
can predict ahead of time if you tell me
how fast it's going where it's gonna go
but these things four tiny objects the
location of the particle becomes kind of
fuzzy and uncertain and the trajectory
that it takes becomes unknowable and if
you look and see which trajectory it
took you can actually change the
situation so one of the strange things
in quantum mechanics is that when you
look at something when you learn
information about it you make a
measurement on it it changes so here's
classical mechanics here's my friend J
Ingram lying on this bed of nails here
and I have this very large sledgehammer
which I just used to smash a cement
block on his stomach and then my friend
here is holding up a piece of plexiglass
to protect Jays face so it'll look good
at the funeral and there's absolutely no
uncertainty here you know that Jay is
going to die
well he didn't really die but you know
exactly with this large object like this
sledgehammer if you if you took a
picture of it and measured how fast it
was going you could predict exactly
where it's going to be a little while
from now but it does not work that way
in quantum mechanics things are rather
different so in the classical world we
say that the fact that you can predict
what's going to happen to the positions
of the particles later given where they
are now and how fast they're going
that's called deterministic evolution
that's a big word it just means that you
can predict the motion of the particles
well it's kind of like that in the
quantum world but unfortunately certain
things that you're sure you should be
able to know you're not allowed to know
it's a very strange circumstance certain
things that you would like to measure
become unknowable or they they seem to
become random each time you do the
experiment you may get a different
result even though you prepared if you
take an electron and shoot it on a path
like a baseball and you always aim it in
exactly the same direction you always
shoot it with exactly the same speed it
doesn't always land in the same place it
chooses a place somehow randomly well
when people began to develop a theory of
this quantum mechanics they realized
that what was happening was that these
very very tiny particles seem to be
acting like waves if you've seen a wave
on the Long Island Sound or on a lake
it's this kind of big object and it's
it's oscillating up and down and you can
to say exactly where it is it's not at
one point it's some kind of large fuzzy
object and it seemed like particles were
acting like waves some of the time and
the inventor of this picture of quantum
mechanics Erwin Schrodinger thought
about the electron as a wave and when
you have a wave you the part somehow
represents where the particle is but you
can't say exactly where it is somehow
it's more likely to be where the wave is
big and less likely to be where the wave
is small but you can't say exactly where
it is Fineman took a different point of
view he said no particles are particles
electrons are definitely particles but
they take paths which you can't predict
which are random and then they even can
take more than one path at the same time
which sounds that's the first of the
things it sounds completely crazy but is
in fact correct and these two ways of
describing quantum mechanics seem
completely different but in fact make
the same predictions and are consistent
with each other but they were just
invented by different people looking at
the physics from a different point of
view so I want to convince you now that
light is made of particles so we have
lights up here coming down shining on
your eyes there's a light from this
screen shining in your eyes but there
are so many billion of these tiny little
particles per second hitting your eyes
that you don't notice the individual
ones although your eye is almost
sensitive enough to detect the
individual ones so the way we can
physicists figured out that light is
made of particles they took a light bulb
and a light an ordinary light bulb emits
energy in the form of light and it is in
the form of these particles called
photons
and there are about 10 to the 18 of
these per second what is 10 to the 18
mean it means 1 the number one followed
by 18 zeros okay it's a what is that
that's a trillion trillion per second of
these particles so each particle doesn't
carry very much energy but there are
lots and lots of them and coming out of
a out of a 5 watt light bulb so we want
to get rid of most of them so we put a
dark gray piece of glass here called a
neutral density filter and it absorbs
almost all of those particles of light
but about one per second maybe escape go
through this dark thing and comes out
the other side and then there's a gadget
called a photomultiplier which when it
receives this little lump of energy this
particle called the photon it detects it
turns it into a burst of electrical
current and you can use that to drive a
loudspeaker and you can hear it click or
you can see a needle move and you can
detect the presence of these particles
so if you do this experiment you'll hear
about one click per second but it's not
click click
click it's not one click every second
like a clock sometimes you get click
click click click click click it's
random sometimes they're too close
together sometimes as a long space you
cannot predict when this photons are
going to arrive it seems to be random
it's like the Amtrak trains you can
never tell when they're gonna come to
New Haven even if there's a schedule so
this proves that these are not waves
because waves deliver their energy
smoothly and continuously all the time
even if they have very low amplitude but
here it's showing that the energy
arrives in discrete lumps called quanta
it's from the german word for for
counting for quantity and that little
lump of energy always has the same size
and makes the loudspeaker click when the
photomultiplier detects it
so that's the first bit of randomness so
instead of a photomultiplier there's
another related way to detect photons
and many of you may actually own such a
thing in your digital if you have a
digital camera inside there is an array
of several million little detectors each
of which is capable of detecting single
photons so here's a special rather it's
a $30,000 digital camera but it's more
or less the same thing and we expose it
to a very very dim source of light and
after one thirtieth of a second you saw
a photon landed right there and made a
little dark spot on the image this is a
kind of negative image and one landed
there and one landed there just at
random and then after one second you see
30 times as many as that roughly there
probably roughly 90 spots there and
you're beginning to detect a little bit
of a pattern they're more likely to
and here and here and here that in the
spaces in between and after a hundred
seconds so a little over a minute and a
half now you can really see that there's
a pattern there's lots of photons
particles landing here and here but not
very many in between and we're going to
come back in a little while and explain
why it's making this pattern but what I
want you to learn from this is that
light really is made of particles and if
only if you try to take a picture of
your friend and you made that you open
the shutter for such a short length of
time and the room was kind of dark so
that only three photons landed on the
film or on the digital camera detector
you just get three randomly located
spots then one time when you do it they
might be here the next time you do it
they might be here here and here it's
completely random and you have no way of
predicting it even if you set up the
experiment the same way over and over
and over again the results are random
and there's no way to find any you're
not there's not any hidden things that
you forgot to take into account that are
explaining why it looks random it really
is random on the other hand things are
kind of predictable because after you do
this when once you have about ten
thousand photons landing then you see a
very clear pattern and those kind of
patterns can turn into a picture of your
friends cat or whatever it is you've
taken a picture of but when you first
have just a few particles of light
landing it's not a full picture it's
just random well let's try to understand
that and let's start with a very so what
if physicists do so that's a very
strange phenomenon we let's say we just
discovered it how do we work as
scientists how do we figure out what to
do well we make a model a model is the
beginnings of a theory a theory is sort
of the highest form of expiries and
explanation it's the best and highest
form
first we're gonna start with a rough
model just an idea maybe it works like
this and we're gonna try out the model
and compare the predictions of the model
to experiment and see what we get
so let's start with a simple model
called geometric optics it's a very nice
thing it says okay lights made of
particles I believe you
and let's just what a particles do well
they probably travel in straight lines
let's try that as a picture of what
happens so here's a little source of
light and here's a little arrow I cut
out of paper and I put here and it casts
a shadow you've all seen you know you
can see shadows from the overhead lights
on the if you hold your hand out on the
floor you can see shadows of the seats
here so it's very simple to explain
shadows this model works great you put
the object there the particles of light
and go and if they hit the object they
get stopped and so that they don't land
on the screen and so they make this dark
area called the shadow and that works if
you have a if you have a you know a
source of light and you you you well I
don't even need that I've got one up
there there's my shadow you know and
it's because I'm intercepting the
particles of light and keeping them from
hitting the screen that makes this
shadow okay so this model the simple
model that lights made of particles and
travels in a straight line
seems to work it's great maybe we've
explained maybe we found a way to
predict how light travels so we could
try a different shaped object and sure
enough we would get a different shaped
shadow and it would make sense
everything would fit with the model well
there's a problem with this model
because you can do another experiment
that shows that the model is no good so
this model of geometric optics worked
great for several hundred years and
people were very happy with it and then
actually Isaac Newton was the first who
sort of invented that model also
realized it had a very serious problem
and the serious problem is that there's
a thing called partial reflection if you
have a piece of glass like a window and
the particles of light come up to the
window some of the particles of light go
through the window and some of them
reflect you can see that at night if you
look outside where it's dark there's no
light coming from outside but you if
there's a brightly lit room that you're
standing and you can see you're a faint
reflection of yourself in the window
it's not a it's kind of acting a little
bit like a mirror even though you know
it lets light through it also reflects
light a little bit it turns out that
with an ordinary piece of glass a 96
percent of the light particles will go
through the glass and about 4 percent
will reflect on average okay and a
particular place where this phenomenon
of partial reflection is used as in your
car rearview mirror so some of you don't
look like you're old enough to drive yet
but maybe you've seen your parents at
night reach up and do something to the
rear view mirror in the car to adjust it
for nighttime use well the way that
works is the following if the idea is
you want to reduce the reflection of the
light from that mirror because the
headlights of the cars behind you will
blind you while you're trying to drive
so car rearview mirrors are made of
glass
and the there's a little it's not a flat
piece of glass it's a wedge that has a
taper like this and on the backside is
some shiny aluminum that makes it a
mirror that reflects almost all the
light so in the daytime you set it up so
that the light coming from the cars
behind you goes bounces off the back
surface and goes to your eyes so you can
see but at night that's too much
the headlights make too much glare and
so you tip the angle of this thing so
that the light that's coming to your eye
is the one that's bouncing off the front
of this wedge the front surface of the
glass that's only about 4% of the light
well what's the problem well here's the
problem if lights
made of particles and I sent to a piece
of glass if I sent one particle of light
is it going to reflect or is it going to
transmit it can only do one or the other
if you put a detector or a
photomultiplier behind and it transmits
it will click if you and if it reflects
and you have a detector back here that
one will click but they'll never both
click it can't go both places at the
same time so what does it mean that 96%
of the particles transmit and 4% reflect
it means that there's some randomness
that if you send in a hundred particles
of light typically four of them will
reflect and ninety-six will transmit but
which ones you cannot know you cannot
predict ahead of time when you do the
experiment I'm going to send in one
particle of light and I'm going to
measure whether it transmitted or
reflected the result is random 96% of
the time it will transmit but 4% of the
time it will reflect and you can't tell
what's going to happen until you do the
experiment then you do the experiment
over again with exactly the same setup
launch exactly the same light energy and
sometimes the result will be different
you can't predict so Newton actually was
aware that this was a problem for his
particle theory of light but he didn't
know how to get around it and quantum
mechanics didn't come along to explain
it for another couple of hundred years
well there's some more strange things
experiments you can do which show that
this model of geometric optics is no
good and this brings us to maybe you've
heard of this Heisenberg uncertainty
principle that people talk about a lot
but understand less usually when they're
talking about it so it turns out that if
you measure the position of a particle
very very accurately so you know where
it is
you cannot tell after that which way
it's moving
that when you make a measurement you
actually change the system so in the
part in the geometric optics if I had a
nice beam of particles of light coming
like this and I put a little tiny hole
in a screen then what will happen well
these guys will all be stopped casting a
big shadow here and the particles that
are exactly lined up to go through that
tiny hole will go straight through and
they'll all land right there so you do
the experiment you have to make this
hole very tiny about a millionth of a
meter in diameter or meters about this
big a hundredth of a meters about that
big a millimeter you can just see with
your eye and this is a thousand times
smaller than a millimeter but once you
make it that small you find out that
instead of going straight after you've
determined that the position of the
particles is exactly here because they
had to be there to go through the hole
they come out in random direction
sometimes when you send one particle in
it comes out up here and lands on the
screen there sometimes when you send it
through it comes out down here and lands
on the screen there you cannot predict
where the particles are going to land
and that's this uncertainty principle if
you're very very certain about the
position the height of where the
particle went through the screen which
you are because it went through the hole
you're now very uncertain about which
direction it's heading afterwards that's
called the phenomenon of diffraction and
cannot be explained by geometric optics
so this position and the direction that
are called incompatible observables if
you know one you can't know the other
well now we come to the really really
strange part of quantum mechanics
suppose that and I put that one slit
there and I got that distribution of
where the particles land now let me open
a second slit so I should get twice as
many particles going through and the
light should get brighter well in some
places
the particles never land and in other
places they land more frequently so
imagine if you had two flashlights and
you turned on them both it would get
twice as bright right so whenever you
open a second source of light you expect
to get more intensity more particles
landing everywhere but instead you get
four times as likely that they'll land
here and they won't land here at all
that's very very strange so opening a
second slit actually causes the light
intensity to decrease in certain places
something that just makes sounds crazy
doesn't make any sense at all so somehow
it turns out that if you send in a
single particle of light and it comes
here and it might have gone through this
slit or it might have gone through that
slit it has a choice of two
possibilities then something strange
happens to the probabilities of where it
can land sometimes it can't go to
certain places and that's the experiment
that I showed you with that digital
camera there were two slits and the
particles are arriving randomly and
landing at different places but they
have a higher probability of landing in
certain places like this and almost no
probability of landing in the
intervening spaces opening the second
slit made that light intensity here go
down very very strange so this is
Feynman like to call quantum weirdness
it a particle takes so he said let's
make up a crazy rule to explain this
crazy experiment experimental result
let's say that each particle of light
takes all possible paths from the light
bulb to the detector it's not like a
baseball that you've launched it and it
goes along the same path every time you
do the experiment here every time you do
the experiment the particle doesn't
choose one path randomly it takes both
paths at the same time
well what that's very strange
and basically it means we cannot know
which path the particle took because
that would affect the result well that's
a pretty strange idea on the other hand
the results of the experiment are pretty
strange so let's see if it works so
there's a second rule and the rule that
Fineman made up to see if it would fit
the experiment was that each particle
carries a kind of stopwatch a little
clock with a second hand that turns
around very very fast
well we won't it turns around 10 to the
15 times per second we won't worry about
that how fast that is let's just say
it's keeping time okay so each clock
carries a each particle carries a clock
that runs at some rate which is
determined by the color or the frequency
of the light and here's the really
strange rule it says you should pretend
the particle took this path see how long
it took by what time the clock says when
it gets to the detector and then pretend
that it took this path also and see what
time that clock reads when it hits the
detector maybe this path is longer than
that path so the clock readings are not
the same because it takes longer to
reach the screen and then there's a rule
for combining these clock readings to
calculate the probability that the
particle actually landed there and that
rule is the following you take the
little arrow that represents the second
hand on the first the clock from the
first path and the second one and you
add them together like vectors for those
of you that know what those are you just
put the tail of one on the head of the
other and then you draw a line from the
beginning of the first one to the end of
the second one and then you make that
into a square and the area of that
square when it's big that tells you
there's a big chance that the particle
will have Lant taken those paths and
landed at that place and when it's small
then there's not much probability that
that will happen so the area of the
square determines
the likelihood that the particle will
arrive at this particular random
destination and so sometimes when the
particles take the same length of time
or the arrows on the second hands are
parallel then the length from there to
there is very big and you get a big
square sometimes the arrows are lined
like this and when you go from the
beginning of one to the end of the other
you get a very tiny square this is
called interference this is called
constructive interference this is called
destructive interference and it means
that if the arrows line up like this you
have a high probability of going to that
place as they line up like this you have
almost no chance of going to that place
so you get this very strange result that
sometimes when you have two different
ways to go to the same place you would
think it would get easier to go there
you can't get there how weird is that so
that's what's going on here when you
look at pads here that are symmetric
that is that they that you go here and
here and then they're there and the
length of the path is the same then the
clock readings will be the same because
it takes the same length of time the
arrow the first path arrow and the
second path arrow will be parallel
you'll get a big square and there are
four lots of probability of landing
there and then four other places
they'll be out of phase like this you'll
get a small probability and then as you
go further they'll be parallel again and
you'll get a big probability and that
explains this so-called two slit
interference pattern where you get lots
of probability here and none there when
you open the second path now you say
well that's crazy how can it take both
paths at the same time I can just find
out which path it took I will put a
little detector here and when the
particle goes by my detector will click
and I'll say ah when it took path one
well you can do that experiment and when
you do it it destroys that interference
pattern the act of finding out
becoming certain which path it took
ruins the interference effect because it
turns out when you study quantum
mechanics carefully that when you
measure that it went through here that
measurement act randomly resets the
position of the second hand on the clock
and destroys that nice interference
pattern so which path it took is
unknowable you can't know it no matter
how hard you try and if you try and
measure you change the results of the
experiment very very bizarre well what
happens if you have many many slits I
showed you first in one slit then you
got something funny with two slits maybe
you get something very strange with many
many slits and here is an example and
you can do some of these demonstrations
I brought some with me you're welcome to
come up afterwards and do some you find
out that you can take a compact disc
like this favorite any favorite music
disc except Bach because that's
classical it turns out that these
compact discs have many many many slits
in them kind of and they they like this
and it turns out that the angle that the
light reflects from that mirrored that
shiny mirrored surface isn't like an
ordinary mirror where you come in at one
angle and you go out at the same angle
now the angle that it comes out depends
on the color of the light and if you
take one of these compact fluorescent
light bulbs and look at it through this
by reflecting it off this compact disc
you will see all these funny different
colored lines and that's also quantum
mechanics in action because inside this
light bulb over here is a mixture of
gases and the atoms inside that gas have
their electrons get excited by the
electricity in there and they jump up to
different quantum mechanical orbits that
the electrons can take inside the atom
and then when they fall down they emit
light of different colors different
energies and you can see those
individual quantum mechanics
events by just looking at this light
through this funny grading you can also
just to show you illustrate this effect
so here's the CD and I can take this
laser pointer and so on an ordinary
mirror the light would just go down and
bounce up at one angle but if you look
closely here you can see many many
different reflections of the light if I
hold things still you see there's a spot
near the bottom of the picture one
further up and there's one up on the
ceiling and there's another one on the
ceiling and another one I better not go
any further so the light doesn't just
bounce off at one angle it bounces off
at several different angles and if you
send in one particle of light which
would be too dim for us to see it would
choose one of those angles randomly and
sometimes it would go here sometimes
there sometimes they're very strange
okay so I guess the message is that when
it comes to quantum mechanics you have
to think differently so I'll be happy to
show you some demonstrations afterwards
including one with a dusty mirror that's
kind of fun thank you very much
you